[Musique]
12 avril prochain nous avons nos
élections internes
ces élections internes vont se dérouler
dans chacune de nos fédérations
départementales c'est un moment
essentiel de démocratie au sein de notre
famille politique
toutes les équipes qui vont être élus
dans chacun des départements ces équipes
vont être celle qui vont préparer les
élections départementales les élections
régionales
et puis bien sûr ensuite les élections
présidentielles vont pouvoir voter tous
nos militants à jour de cotisation au 31
décembre 2020 mais également pour les
nouveaux qui veulent nous rejoindre
aujourd'hui il reste une semaine c'est à
dire jusqu'au 12 mars pour pouvoir être
inscrit sur nos listes électorales je
compte vraiment sur vous sur votre
mobilisation sur votre participation
il va s'agir de renouveler nos
présidents de fédérations
départementales les délégués de
circonscription les membres du conseil
national vraiment la cheville ouvrière
du militantisme de toute l'organisation
de notre famille politique
tous ceux qui vont organiser diriger
mené là la campagne et qui sont en fait
la cheville ouvrière ou plutôt le coeur
battant de notre famille politique
vous savez que vous pouvez compter sur
nous vous savez que vous pouvez compter
sur votre équipe dirigeante
mais aujourd'hui c'est de vous dont on a
besoin on a besoin d'avoir des équipes
départementales qui soit renouvelée
parce que vous allez être pendant sept
années de campagne départemental
régional élections présidentielles le
coeur battant de famille politique est
vraiment moi je compte sur votre
mobilisation
je compte sur votre engagement je compte
sur votre prise de responsabilité
[Musique]